à l'époque l'état est musulman était
très fragile était nouveau parce
pour donner une laissant à
qui pense à venir montrer comme un
cheval de troie
faire semblant qu'ils sont musulmans
puis appeler trahir étudié de
l'intérieur il y avait ces versets la
celi à des circonstances de la vie du
prophète à médine surtout où il faisait
face à des difficultés et où arrivaient
des révélations du corps un des messages
du coran pour donner des réponses à des
problèmes concrets
il y avait des bédouins qui venait
prendre les fichiers les prophètes ils
étaient affamés qu'il était malade et
lui ont demandé ed est le refuge qui
l'ont ils ont adhéré à l'islam et les a
nourris la donner et il les a logés il
les a renvoyés avec son berger avec les
chats monde et la communauté parce que
les amendes et toute la communauté
après certains période une fois qu'ils
se seront bien nourris bien logés ils
ont trahi
ils ont tué les bergers ils ont profané
une corde hiver du berger ils sont
partis avec les chameaux et à
l'internement me remets des tacles et là
comme pacificateur mais ce ne serait pas
de journal mail conflits entre tribus
amies lui même alors il y avait beaucoup
d'éléments concrets qui suppose l
exercice de la fosse jusqu'à la violence
le courant n'a désigné benjamin que
qu'incarne terme d'un messager de dieu
points alors il faut que les gens
comprennent que le coran à part quelques
principes de base c'était un guide pour
le prophète et non pas pour nous les
musulmans n'importe où n'importe quand